[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: We have two
wonderful guests today.
I'm going to introduce both.
So our first guest
is Kate T. Parker.
Kate is a mother,
a wife, an Ironman,
and a professional photographer.
Her book, "Strong is
the New Pretty," which
we have back there,
is a photo series
that's led to collaborations
with brands such as Disney's,
Kellogg's, and NBC.
And Kate is the mother to two
daughters, Ella and Alice,
who's also here today.
And then our second
guest is Andrew Ference.
Andrew is a former NHL player.
Played for 16 seasons, including
on the 2011 Bruins Stanley Cup
team.
Andrew is currently the Director
of Social Impact at the NHL,
and he's the father to his
two daughters, Ava and Stella.
So, welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks, for being here.
KATE T. PARKER: Hi.
SPEAKER 1: All right.
Perfect.
So we'll get into our theme.
We're here to talk about
empowering kids through sports.
And we'll get to
that, but I want
to start a little bit
about your careers
and becoming the professionals
at the highest level.
So Kate, let's kick
it off with you.
You're an amazing photographer,
but this wasn't your profession
at first.
When did you decide to become
a full-time professional
photographer?
And how did you get into it?
KATE T. PARKER:
So my background,
like right out of school, was
I was a video editor at CNN.
And then I moved
into advertising,
and I worked as a producer.
So I was used to making
things on a screen compelling.
And then I had my first
daughter 13 years ago.
And like a lot of
parents, I started
taking pictures
of what I thought
was the most beautiful
thing ever in the world.
But my taste level was
pretty high from working
with art directors
for years, and my--
like, I didn't know
how to shoot manually,
so I taught myself on YouTube.
And I taught myself how to edit
pictures same way, on YouTube.
And no grand ambition, besides
I would just sit on the couch
and take pictures of
my feet, because that
was what was there,
and trying to focus it,
and trying to make, like,
have that pretty, blurred
background.
And I just shot.
I mean, I think for me, because
I was an athlete growing up,
I was just pretty
annoyingly diligent
about trying to get better
and to have my taste level
and my skill level meet.
And I'm still
working towards that.
But that's kind of how
it started for me, just
trying to, like every
other parent, trying
to take pictures, like pretty
pictures of their kids.
SPEAKER 1: Andrew, you probably
knew a little earlier on.
I think you said you
left in high school
to go play at a prep team.
So when did you
know that the NHL
was kind of a realistic
expectation or possibility?
ANDREW FERENCE: It
was late in the game.
I was a multi-sport
kid growing up.
I played every sport under
the sun at school-- a lot
of lacrosse, rugby, and
obviously a lot of hockey.
But up until the day I left
to go play junior hockey down
in Portland, Oregon, I was still
playing all those other sports,
and to this day still
play other sports.
So the NHL to me was always
like this lottery ticket.
You know, you work really hard,
you do everything you can,
but even at that there's so
much that's out of your control.
So it was kind of
a dream, but not
one that I really relied on.
So probably about
like 17 years old,
I started playing against
other people, guys
that were older than me that
eventually started making it.
And when I saw those
guys make it, I was like,
I can play against those
guys, so maybe there's
a chance, right?
But you know, I was probably
three years into my NHL career
before I felt like, oh,
actually I belong here.
Like, it felt real.
SPEAKER 1: So talk a little
bit about your NHL career.
What was the highlight?
ANDREW FERENCE: Well,
highlight's easy.
That's we won the Stanley
Cup with the Boston Bruins.
I mean, that was far and away
the most amazing sporting
experience, and probably
even more amazing
because I had lost it.
In Calgary, we lost in the
seventh game of the Stanley Cup
final to the Tampa
Bay Lightning,
which quite literally--
I'm almost embarrassed
to say, but I
would wake up at night
years later just like,
oh, like, what if?
It's like just post-traumatic
about that series.
So winning it was not only
great because we won it,
but it actually erased all
those demons from losing it.
So far and away, the highlight.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
And Kate, a little bit about
some of the iconic brands
you've worked with, like, what
has that experience been like,
just reaching, becoming a
professional photographer,
getting asked to work with
Disney's and Kellogg's and
NBC's?
KATE T. PARKER: I
mean, it's crazy to me,
because, like I said, I
did not go to photo school.
You know?
And it just started, and
it still remains, like,
a one-person business
in my studio, which
is in the basement of
my house in Atlanta.
So it's not like, oh, of
course, Disney's calling.
Of course, you know?
I literally remember
getting a phone call
from somebody at Disney.
I was in the car,
and I thought it
was a friend calling as a joke.
And I was like, "the" Disney?
I had to double-check.
But I really enjoy
it, because I'm
so passionate about the message
that my book puts forward
and that my image
has put forward.
And when larger companies
with a greater platform
want to share that same
message of empowerment
for girls and self-acceptance,
I'm 100% on board.
And I'm so glad,
just because I feel
like there's so much
of what our girls see,
and women see, is not real
and doesn't reflect what
they look like or act like.
So if we can put
imagery out there
that is real girls doing real
things and being themselves,
and if these larger
brands get behind it,
I'm so excited because I
get to combine what I do
and what I love to do, but
with just a bigger platform.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
So that's a perfect transition.
I want you to explain--
we have one of the
most interesting photos
that you've shared, so
if you could tell us
the story behind this photo.
KATE T. PARKER: Oh.
So OK, this is my
older daughter, Ella.
And she was-- I think
she was nine at the time,
and she was getting ready
to do her first triathlon.
So if you've ever
done a triathlon,
you go to the race
expo the day before,
and they give you everything.
You get your bike set up,
and you get your swim cap,
your race number.
But it's super intimidating
because everybody there
looks like they know
what they're doing.
And she came back, and
she had all her stuff,
and she was like,
Mom, I can't do it.
I'm not ready, I
don't want to do it.
And I was like,
get your stuff on,
and come meet me
downstairs in the studio.
And I snapped maybe
three pictures.
I said to her, show
me your toughest look.
Show me how brave you are.
And I literally took the
camera and I flipped it around.
And I said, don't you think
this girl can do a triathlon?
And she was like,
oh, yeah, I think so.
I showed her who she was,
she just didn't believe it.
And she went out the next
day and she killed it.
And one of the reasons that I
love this picture so much is
it's the cover of our book.
And it just shows--
I had no idea.
There was no book at the time.
There was no message.
I just was taking a picture
so she would go do the race.
And I just love the power in
it and how strong and confident
she looks.
And I just love
remembering that story.
Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: So we're going
to talk about your parenting
style and, just in
general, the theme.
But talk to us a
little bit about how
your parents influenced you
both getting to the highest
level of your professions,
and how has that impacted
your current parenting style.
KATE T. PARKER: Sure.
You want to take that one?
ANDREW FERENCE: Yeah.
I mean, my parents, neither
of them were big into sports.
I mean, they were
active and whatnot.
But my dad did some judo, and
squash, and stuff like that,
but never hockey.
But they always supported
whatever I was interested in.
And the only thing
that they ever demanded
was that, if you start
something, you finish it.
And you do your absolute best,
like you put your most effort
into it.
So whether that was
homework, sports, anything.
And the only time
my dad ever gave me
any, like, sporting
advice is it'd
be along the lines of, you know,
we're up 6-0 in a hockey game,
and on the ride home,
he'd be like, you know,
I noticed during
the third period
you kind of relaxed a bit.
And he's like, that's really
disrespectful to the other team
to not try your hardest,
even though you're winning.
Like, you shouldn't goof around.
You know, so that
kind of approach
of, always finish a job, do it
properly from start to finish,
no matter the circumstances.
You know, his view was, if
he walked into the arena
and we were up 8-0
or down 8-0, he
shouldn't be able to
tell by the effort
that I was putting
in on the ice.
And so that was always a big
lesson for me and, I think,
carries over to my
two girls where I just
want them to enjoy what they're
doing and work really hard.
And I think that those two
things combined can create
magic in anything, you know?
And I don't care what sport
it is or what line of work
or whatever their interests
are, but you do that
and you'll have a
pretty good life.
KATE T. PARKER: That
was great advice.
Yeah.
For me, I grew up playing
soccer, and it 100%
informed my approach to
everything and my approach
to parenting, as well.
My parents never, ever told me--
I have two older brothers
and an older sister,
so I'm the youngest of four.
And my older brothers
all played soccer.
And my parents never said--
because at the time, there was
not soccer teams for girls.
And they never said that.
They just said,
sure, you can play.
And I would play with boys.
And then there became
soccer teams for girls.
But they never, ever said--
you know, because I was loud
and kind of in your face.
And they never said girls are
not supposed to be like that,
and girls are supposed--
I had a temper.
And I mean, they would
try to curb my temper,
but they never said,
little girls are quiet.
And I mean, I try to do the
same and pass that along
to my girls.
I never thought that,
because of my sex,
I would be limited by anything.
And I try to do the
same for my girls,
that whatever they're
interested in, they can do it.
Like Andrew said, you
know, as long as you dig in
and you work hard.
I don't care what
they want to do.
It does not have to be sports.
Alice is 100%
interested in singing.
And you've just
got to work hard.
Whatever it is, we
will support you.
You've just got to work hard.
SPEAKER 1: So let's get
into the theme today, which
is empowering kids through
sports and, really, just
in general.
So let's talk a little
about your photo series.
We have a couple
more examples here.
"Strong is the New Pretty,"
which you turned into a book,
but also is, again, a series.
How did you come
up with the idea?
And where did this spawn from?
KATE T. PARKER: So for
years, I just shot my girls
as they were.
And after maybe
four or five years,
I was asked to be part of
the gallery show in Atlanta.
And so I had to cull
through thousands of images
to find the 20 strongest.
And at that point,
I was just shooting.
I wasn't shooting
with a purpose,
I wasn't shooting with
the idea that there was
going to a book or a message.
But looking at the 20 images
that I selected for the gallery
on the wall, I was like, oh.
It finally dawned on me.
I was like, oh, this is about
showing these girls for who
they are and celebrating
for who they are, which is--
for my girls and the
girls that I shot
were dirty, and fearless,
and silly, and emotional.
They weren't necessarily
smiling for the camera.
And so that gallery show was
a huge bust, and nothing sold.
And that was expensive
as a photographer,
because you pay for your images.
And to print and
frame 20 images, I--
first, I got really
disappointed,
and I was like, oh, I'm
terrible photographer.
And then my temper
came into play,
and I got mad because
I did so much work.
And I really thought that
there was something there,
and so I sent a few like this.
I would send this little
grid of images to three blogs
that I followed.
They were culture and art
blogs about photography.
And then it just kind of
went viral from there.
It went to CNN, the Today
Show, Huffington Post.
All these places were
writing this story,
and I was like, oh, that's
not what I intended at all.
And then the opportunity
from that came to do a book.
And up until that
point, the series
was very narrow in terms
of what strong looked like,
because it looked like my
daughters and their friends.
So I used the book as an
opportunity to expand.
I shot girls all
over the country.
Just really wanted to get
diversity in the message,
and in the interests, and
in where the girl's from.
So that's kind of how it
started, just with me having
a little temper
tantrum that nothing
had sold in my gallery show.
SPEAKER 1: And Andrew, I think
you had a little bit different.
I know you said that
your daughter started
figure skating, which you would
think, as a hockey player,
would be great to
be back at the rink.
But that wasn't
the case, was it?
ANDREW FERENCE: Yeah.
I mean, my story's
all over the map.
I grew up with a sister who was
involved in a lot of sports.
And I think, to Kate's
experience, she had no limits,
do whatever she wants.
But she was really into
dance, and so I kind of
knew that world.
And then having my own
daughters, same thing.
We opened up the books to them,
like try whatever you want--
multi-sport, multi-interest.
But both of them
actually did trend
towards figure skating early on.
They also loved going
to Disney and getting
the bippity boppity
boo [INAUDIBLE],,
the whole nine yards.
I'm like, all right, I'll
support that, whatever.
Just kind of same thing.
You know, I tried to nudge
them one way or another,
but they determined
their own path.
So the path was figure skating.
And the only reason
that sport frustrated me
was because I would go
and watch their practices,
and it's an incredibly
athletic sport.
They'd try over,
and over, and over,
and fall down, and get up.
And to finally nail a new
trick would take so much effort
over weeks, right?
And bumps, and bruises,
and frustrations.
And when they would
finally, nail it,
I was like, man, that's
incredible just how much effort
went into that.
And think of all the
lessons that they learned.
But the kicker was always
the competition day.
And they had to have
the full makeup.
They had to have
the shiny dress,
and they had to smile when
they're doing the routine.
And that was the part that
just always just got me,
because you get less
points if you don't smile.
And I was always
just like, really?
You know?
Because after all those
weeks of watching practice,
and how hard they
worked, and how athletic
they were, I'm like, what
if they don't want to smile?
What if they can
just be an athlete
and be taken at face
value for all the work
that they put into this?
So that was always
kind of the rub.
And then honestly, it
started rubbing them.
And I didn't sit them down and
tell them about this or rant,
and they kind of figured
it out for themselves.
And that kind of, I think,
started getting to them.
So my oldest daughter,
Ava, she made a big jump
from figure skating to rugby.
[LAUGHS] And so now--
KATE T. PARKER: Obviously.
ANDREW FERENCE: Now, she's
right into rugby and loving it.
And you know, I
lean on rugby a lot.
I love it.
I played it growing up a bit.
But the atmosphere--
there's a position
for every type of
athlete on a rugby team.
The first practice
that she went to, there
was different teams
scattered all over the field,
like different age groups,
different sex, everything.
But at the end of
practice, everybody
got together for a big
barbecue and had a big social.
And so you're part of a family.
So I saw a lot of
similarities with hockey.
You know, it's a
smaller niche sport,
but it has that kind
of family atmosphere
and that real strong team bond.
She's good at the sport,
but that atmosphere
is what really dug into her.
And she's part of a
bigger community, I guess.
So to me, I think that
sports like that, that really
encourage all different
types of athletes
and different types
of body types,
and you bring all
these people together,
and you really purposely create
a community and a good feeling
when you leave the
game or the practice,
that's so important, because
that's what keeps kids there.
You know, it's not
winning the medals
and standing on the podium.
That's a quick hit,
and that feels good.
But that atmosphere
of family and feeling
like you're part of
the big group, that
keeps you in love with
the sport for life
and active in the sport.
SPEAKER 1: So this
is for both of you,
but Kate, you kind of
mentioned that there was not
a girls soccer team growing up.
And then rugby is, historically,
a predominantly male sport.
So I think with the evolution
of technology and social media,
how have you seen
sports that maybe
were very gender-specific now
not being as gender-specific?
Have you seen the evolution
with your kids from, I guess,
when you were growing up?
KATE T. PARKER: I mean,
my kids don't ever
think they can't do anything.
My older daughter played
in a flag football league,
and they were the only
girls team in there.
And it's actually
like the perfect age.
I think they were
11, so like right
when they were at
the point where
they were taller than the boys.
And they're 13 now, it
wouldn't work anymore.
But they don't
really seem to feel
like they're defined by,
if girls aren't allowed
or whatever.
I feel like they would
protest that, you know?
They are strong enough to
know, no, this is unfair
and to make a stand.
And I think that they're
open to anything.
And they're like, oh,
that looks like fun.
I want to do that.
Of course, I can do
that, which is great.
ANDREW FERENCE:
Yeah, I grew up--
we had a girl on the
hockey team the whole time
we grew up back in Canada.
And so it wasn't really rare
to have a girl on your team.
But looking back, it's
like there was one girl.
And I imagine her
experience, being
the only girl on the team,
must have been tough.
Obviously now, the participation
levels of girls in hockey
has shot way up.
And that's attributed to great
work by the hockey associations
to deliberately promote
it to girls, as well.
And I think that's
probably the evolution,
is the governing bodies,
places like the NHL,
like deliberately
entering into that space
to provide appropriate
programming for girls
and to have proper
coaching curriculum
and guidebooks on
how to make sure
that this is a good space
for girls to come into
and a good sport where
they feel welcome.
Because you can't just
transfer everything
that you do,
sometimes, and coach
the same way, and everything
down to the locker rooms
that are provided.
There's a lot that goes
into it to make sure
that, if a girl
chooses to play hockey,
that she feels like she's
welcome, she's there.
And so I think that's
probably the biggest change,
is those deliberate
actions taken
by things like USA
Hockey or the NHL
to make sure that this is
a massive priority for us
is to get it right
and to do it right.
And I think that's the big
shift is the focus that's
deliberately being put on it.
SPEAKER 1: One kind of somewhat
sensitive, controversial topic
that comes up a lot with
kids in sports these days is
participation trophies.
Do either of you have
strong opinions on that
that you're willing to share?
KATE T. PARKER:
I've kind of thought
about this a little
bit, and I think
the kids don't even buy them.
If they know everybody gets
it just for being a part,
then it doesn't mean anything.
And I'm not against
making kids feel good,
but if they're smart
enough to recognize
that it's like
getting a T-shirt,
I don't know that it's doing
what you set out to do.
They should be sort
of the top, you know?
If you get a trophy,
it means that you won,
or you were the MVP.
So yeah, my kids have definitely
gotten them over the years.
But the ones that they have
earned and that they won
are the ones that are
sitting out in their rooms.
So I don't know that you're
not fooling any of the kids.
You know?
ANDREW FERENCE: When
I was a kid, yeah,
I never would have wanted
the participation ribbon,
or whatever.
But growing up and becoming
older, and in the job
that I'm in now,
I've been able to be
part of good
presentations by, let's
say, the country of Norway,
who doesn't keep score
in their youth sports
system up until, I think,
the age of 11 or 12.
They're not allowed to
put any sports scores
from youth sports in
newspapers, or print,
or anything like that,
up until the age of 14.
And so they create a real
culture of not keeping score.
Everybody's playing, you know,
that equality in just keeping
kids in a fun environment.
And they've had
incredible success.
Their gold medals per
ratio of population
are absolutely insane
in these sports.
And so there is some merit
to what they're doing
and to the approach that they're
taking not only for their youth
sport participation levels,
which are much higher than most
of ours, they're
keeping kids in sport,
but also producing
extremely elite athletes.
So that's really swayed
me, is the results
that countries have enacted
these kind of rules.
And it's really producing.
And from our perspective,
even at a league level,
our main focus is not to make
the next batch of NHL hockey
players.
Our focus is to make sure that
people come away from a hockey
rink and have a good
experience, because we
want them to stay in the sport.
And when you ask kids,
why did you come back
the following season?
They're like, oh, it was fun.
So to us, that means
our number one priority
is to make sure that
the sport is fun.
If that means going the route
of not necessarily keeping
score, making it--
so our governing
bodies have done a lot.
They've shrunk down the
size of a hockey rink,
and they play a different
form of hockey in a smaller
space for little kids because
it's more fun to actually
be involved in the game, rather
than just watching the good kid
steal the puck and skate off.
So there are actual
changes in our games
that we've made at a higher
level to produce more fun.
And I think that's basically
what it falls down to, for us.
SPEAKER 1: So
Andrew, earlier you
talked, when we spoke before,
about teaching your daughters
about who they are versus
who they want to become
and who they want to be.
Can you talk a little bit about
how that mentality has played
a role in your parenting?
ANDREW FERENCE:
Well, I want them
to, obviously, like I
said, shoot for the stars
and, if they have a
dream of doing something,
know that they can do it.
Like, the world is their oyster.
They're obviously
extremely privileged.
They have great,
great schooling.
They have every
opportunity in the world,
but they have to use it and
not waste that opportunity.
And so I think giving
them every option,
exposing them to as
many things as possible
and making sure that
they know that they're
capable to try
something new and do it,
that's probably
the conversation we
have the most when we have
our deep dad-daughter talks.
Like, why are we
doing something?
Or what is our philosophy?
It really is, as
I said, what I am
trying to give you the ability
to do is, when you're older
and you have a group of friends,
or you have some co-workers,
you have a new boy that you
like or girl that you like,
or whatever it is, and they
say, hey, let's go do this,
you can say, yep, let's do it,
even if you've never done it
before, because you have the
confidence and the capabilities
to try new things.
I've ran into a
lot of people, even
at a professional
sports level, that
were afraid to go play a game
of tennis because they're like,
oh, I've never played tennis.
And these are
professional NHL players,
like, I don't want
to play tennis.
I've never played that before.
But what it was
is because they're
scared to not be
good at something,
or they had that lack
of self-confidence
to try something
new and understand
that it's all right to
not be great at something.
And so I guess
that's really what
I want to give them
the ability to,
is to try as many
things as possible,
to jump into scary situations,
to try something wild once
in a while and not be afraid
of being a little bit afraid.
So I guess, yeah, that's a
long-winded answer to it.
SPEAKER 1: That's great.
I want to go back--
maybe there too-- to
Kate, to your photos.
KATE T. PARKER: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: And this is, I
believe, a year or two old now,
but why do you think
these photos still
resonate so much today?
KATE T. PARKER:
Well, sadly, I think
it's rare to see-- like
on social media, most
everything we see is
filtered, or face-tuned,
or set up to show an unrealistic
depiction of women or girls.
And I feel like this
shows who these girls are.
It shows a rawness
and a realness
to what girls are interested in.
Like, they're screaming.
They're sweating.
They're playing baseball.
They're enjoying when they
clean the fire hydrants.
And yeah, I think
that people see these,
and it either reminds them
of who they used to be,
or reminds them of who
their kids are now,
as parents and stuff.
Like this picture in the middle
of Alice, that's my daughter,
has gotten stolen so many times.
And it's a meme.
It says, remember her?
Remember when you
used to be this girl?
And I don't even mind anymore.
I'm like, if this is encouraging
people to remember when they--
because I feel like when
you're a kid, before you
reach puberty, you have
this sense of I am awesome.
I can do anything.
And then it just kind of
gets-- not beaten out of you,
but you just lose it.
And if these remind
people of when
they had a sense of
possibility and when
they had a sense that they
were such badasses, that if it
can remind people of that--
I think that's why people
respond to it because that's
what these girls are.
Because when I shoot girls,
when I shoot them for the book,
I'm generally shooting
them doing the thing
that they love the most, the
thing that is their passion.
And they are confident, and
I think it comes through.
So people want to see
that, because I think we
all need more of that.
SPEAKER 1: And that's
a good transition to,
what are you working on next?
KATE T. PARKER: OK.
SPEAKER 1: We have the cover.
KATE T. PARKER: Yeah.
So this is my nephew.
And so the other cover
is my other daughter.
So Alice, my
daughter, is not happy
that she's not on the
cover of a book yet.
[LAUGHTER]
We're working on it, Al.
So this is my nephew,
AND this book is called,
"The Heart of a Boy."
And it was funny,
because I was asked
to consider doing
a book about boys,
and I was very reluctant
because I was like,
no, boy's voices are heard.
I need to talk about our girls.
You know, that's
what my focus was.
I literally was crying about it.
And then I was like, you
know, I told my publisher,
I said, I'll try.
I'll try to shoot a little bit.
And I shot just a few
sessions with boys
that were local to me.
And immediately, I realized that
the vulnerability and the depth
of feeling that these
boys had was something
that I wasn't aware of,
something that I didn't
realize needed to be heard.
And throughout the tour for
"Strong is the New Pretty",
and every time I would
speak, little boys
would say, where's my book?
Miss Kate, are you going
to do the book about boys?
And I was like, y'all
don't need a book at all.
You're fine.
And then I was like--
I was unaware of this.
And through the
shooting of it, I
realized that-- so the
definition, and even in 2018,
for girls is fairly
narrow of what they can be
and what they can do.
But I feel like there's
so much that's helping
to broaden that and so many
opportunities for girls
to be who they want.
And there's books, and
clothing, and TV shows.
But for boys in 2018, the
definition is even more narrow.
So if you step out of
that athlete-leader,
you're kind of lost.
And so I wanted to take that
same message of acceptance
of self and celebration of
self and extend it to boys.
So with "Strong is
the New Pretty,"
the focus was on more
about toughness and grit.
And for "Heart of a Boy,"
I focused a little bit more
on the sensitivity,
and vulnerability,
and including everything.
But I just wanted those
boys' voices to be heard.
And I really, really enjoyed it.
And I'm so excited
for it to come out.
It comes out in April.
SPEAKER 1: Exciting.
And Andrew, you
work for the NHL?
ANDREW FERENCE: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: What are
you working on in terms
of the social impact?
ANDREW FERENCE: We have
a great team at the NHL.
It's a new department.
My boss, Kim Davis, was
brought in in January
from completely
outside of hockey.
And she's been just a dynamo.
She's put together a team
of people here in New York
and in Toronto.
We do social impact,
legislative affairs,
and we help to look for growth
initiatives in the game.
So I get to spread myself
out across those three.
Probably right now,
the most I'm doing
is in legislative affairs,
especially up in Canada,
in Ottawa.
And I get to take the passion
for getting kids involved
in sport and have more access to
sport specifically to females,
just because the participation
numbers are lower.
And in Canada, I get
the distinct advantage
because our health care
system is universal.
So I can really go in
there with good hard data.
We have good partnerships
through the Aspen Institute
with John Hopkins and
some different groups
that have some unbelievable data
on the cost of non-active kids.
How much that costs us,
society-wise, as far
as health care costs,
is astronomical.
So a lot of the work is going in
and having these conversations
with government
officials, looking
for more access to sport,
everything from infrastructure
funding to programming,
and really tying it
to the importance of
the investment in having
kids play sport--
physical health, mental health,
the grades you get at school,
staying out of the
justice system.
I think sport truly is--
it's not just a passion,
and it's not just about
winning medals at the Olympics,
but it really is an
incredibly important part
of the health of our countries.
So yeah, going strong
with those messages
and, thankfully, have
very receptive ears.
And I think that there's a lot
of really, really good people,
both in not just our
league at the NHL,
but across all of the
professional leagues--
we have a lot of crossover--
and then at a government level.
It's just a matter
of getting it right,
and making sure that the funding
is going where it needs to be,
and that we're really accessing
the kids that need it.
There's a lot of kids
that play every sport,
like I did growing up.
But unfortunately,
there's a ton of kids
that have access to no sport.
And so that's really
what we're trying to do
is making sure that
we don't have tons
of kids falling in the cracks.
And we want those
kids playing hockey
and being introduced our sport.
We really see our
sport not only as good
for being active and
whatnot, but to that point
of feeling like you're
part of a better community.
And through our
curriculum and coaching,
we're really pushing
those messages
of confidence, teamwork,
humility, a family setting.
Those are all extremely
important to us.
Like I said, creating
the next NHLers
is not a priority at all.
So I have a lot of fun at work.
I've got great
people to work with.
SPEAKER 1: And it's a little bit
of the Hockey is for Everyone?
ANDREW FERENCE: Hockey is
for Everyone, you know?
And we're really trying to not
just have that as a tagline,
but live it.
And we have a lot of work to do.
Hockey is, like I said,
it's a bit of a niche sport.
It's very regional.
If you looked at us compared to
the demographics in the States,
they don't line up.
And so that is a
big push for us.
We have markets
across North America.
And we need to have the
people playing our sport
look like our markets.
Yeah.
So that's a big job, but
it's important to us.
SPEAKER 1: Perfect.
I want to open it up
to audience questions.
So we have two
microphones on both sides.
While people are
lining up, I have
a question that is off-topic.
But when you Google
Image search, Kate,
you get some wonderful
photos that we've seen.
KATE T. PARKER:
[INAUDIBLE] This is scary.
SPEAKER 1: If you
Google Image search you,
Andrew, a very infamous
situation in a playoff game
pops up.
And we do have a picture of it.
And I think you called this
an equipment malfunction?
[LAUGHTER]
So I'd love to hear
what happened here.
I think a lot of people
have always wondered--
ANDREW FERENCE:
It's a long story.
SPEAKER 1: --the
backstory behind this.
ANDREW FERENCE:
[SIGHING] My daughter
gets this same picture.
And it's even
better on Instagram
where she's got
buddies at school.
She's 13 now.
So she'll get the Instagram post
of funniest hockey [INAUDIBLE]
ever.
And so she'll get
DM'd all these.
And she's like,
thanks a lot, Dad.
But the story behind
it is fairly long.
I was playing for
Boston, obviously,
and this game was in
Montreal, in the playoffs.
For those that don't
know, Boston-Montreal
is the ultimate
rivalry in hockey.
This was years into the rivalry.
We had faced off
against each other.
And it's for real.
We'd go up to Montreal
and play up there,
and they'd be outside of
our hotel at 3 o'clock
in the morning,
pulling the semi horns,
like, wha, wha, pulling the
fire alarm, rocking our bus,
like all kinds of crazy stuff.
And then the Boston fans would
be just as friendly to them,
probably, when they
came down to us.
And so this rivalry
was for real.
So anyways, in this
game, we're down--
down in the game,
down in the series.
And I got kind of a lucky
bounce and scored a goal.
And this is just like
pure, raw, stupid emotion.
And not until after
the game, it was like,
oh, that was really dumb.
KATE T. PARKER: So this
was your celebration?
ANDREW FERENCE: This
was my celebration.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: [INAUDIBLE]
celebration.
ANDREW FERENCE: In Montreal.
And it was a really
dumb thing to do,
because obviously,
you don't want
to get suspended in the
playoffs and whatnot.
And so I just was like--
I didn't even know.
I've got to figure a way
out of this situation.
I explained it to my
kids like, sometimes, you
do a lot of stupid things
in the quest for victory,
and this is one of
those stupid things.
So I made up an excuse that--
you know, I didn't
want to get suspended,
so I said, well, I was
just giving a fist pump.
And I was wearing brand new
gloves, and they got stuck.
And I'm like, I'm really sorry.
They're just stiff.
KATE T. PARKER: Just
that one finger.
[LAUGHS]
ANDREW FERENCE: The league
official on the other line,
you could tell, he
was just like, really?
So I got fined.
I took a pretty good
fine for that one.
And I feel really bad.
I feel more stupid
about lying about it.
I should have just owned it,
but there's some humor to it.
I get a lot of Montreal
fans that actually give it
right back to me, so yeah.
[LAUGHS]
But the funniest
part of the story
is actually going
back to Boston.
And Boston fans are literally
the best sports fans,
bar none in the entire world.
And I end up back.
And I live in the North End
in the Italian area of Boston.
And I show up to my condo, and
on the buzzer board-- you know,
when you buzz in to get into
your building-- so I walk up,
and there's all these envelopes
taped to the buzzer board.
And I'm looking at them.
Open up, and there's
notes, like, go Bruins!
Whatever.
And they're full of money.
So people knew that I had
been fined for doing this.
KATE T. PARKER: Oh, my god.
ANDREW FERENCE: And so the
neighborhood was taping up--
KATE T. PARKER: Oh.
ANDREW FERENCE: So they paid
off some of it, at least.
[LAUGHTER]
And we ended up winning
the Cup that year.
So the North End lore is that
this is what turned the tide
and got us the Cup, right?
But it's, yeah, infamous,
to say the least.
KATE T. PARKER: It's funny.
SPEAKER 1: Is there
anybody that has questions?
I'll get this off
the screen for you.
ANDREW FERENCE: Yeah.
Yeah.
I have artwork at home.
And this guy made this big--
not collage, but kind of like
a really nice portrait of that.
And I was like, oh.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
KATE T. PARKER: That's awesome.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks, so much for coming.
My name is Carissa.
I have two young girls.
I have a question
more around, Kate,
what you were talking
about, was how
to inspire girls to think that
they can accomplish anything.
I think I've seen,
actually, a lot
of the opposite in
my daughter, who's
turning five, very early on,
saying, this is for boys,
and this is for girls, coming
from a lot of different areas.
And I thought taking the
picture of your daughter
and really showing her how
you see her through your eyes
and the world can see you is
a really good example of how
to inspire that.
But can you talk
more about other ways
to help girls see
themselves as being
able to accomplish anything?
KATE T. PARKER: Yeah.
I mean, that's so young.
And yeah.
And I'm sure if
you're questioning it,
you're not the one saying
to her, girls don't do that.
And you're like, where
is this coming from?
And I mean, I think one of
the things that you can do
is just--
I know five is young--
but you can just
have those conversations
of, no, no, no, no,
you can do anything and then
actually it going into practice
and challenging her.
And go to a climbing gym, or
whatever she's interested in.
That's one of the
things that I think
is so important for us, as
parents, is to parent the kids
that we have, not who
we wish they were.
So kind of let her self-direct.
Whatever she likes to do,
be fully invested in it
and take or do it.
But yeah.
And I feel like it's a constant.
For me, it's a
constant conversation
I have with my kids.
I remember, I took
a picture of this.
We walked into Target, or we
walked into a store, whatever
the store is, and it
had like building sets,
and then girls building sets.
And I said to the girls, and
I was like, how dumb is that?
And they're like, yeah,
that's really dumb.
And I think it's just like a
constant, hey, do you see this?
Why is this aisle pink?
Girls don't always like pink.
Do you want to go
to the other aisle?
Let's go get something else.
You're not always having
a big conversation.
It's just little things that
you're always being like,
no, let's question that.
That's silly.
Why is that?
And it's just like
you're always going to be
the mom questioning things.
But then that's good, because
that's what she's doing.
And I think it's probably
she's getting it from school,
or TV shows, or whatever.
So I think it's just, you
just have to be vigilant.
And if you're wondering
about it, then
then you're going to do it.
And I think it's getting
books that teach other--
and there's so much
stuff for girls
to help them recognize
that there's not limits.
It's just constantly
questioning gender roles.
I have a journal, "Strong
is the New Pretty" journal.
And one of the activities
in there is to go in a store
and pick out three things
that are based on gender norms
and write them down, just
to make kids aware of it.
Because we don't even
recognize it, sometimes.
So I think it's
just being aware,
and then being like,
that's pretty dumb.
But it's hard.
That's so young.
Good job, though, good
job for recognizing it.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks, for being here.
My name is Melissa, I
am not a parent yet.
I am an athlete.
I'm a fitness coach, so
this is all really valuable
for me to listen to.
So as somebody who
isn't a parent,
but really appreciates being
involved in the athlete
community-- not necessarily
to your point, Andrew,
of developing
professional athletes,
but just getting women,
girls, involved in sport--
I think, from
personal experience,
we're living in
a space right now
with all this
social media where,
even as an amateur
athlete, or as somebody
who is a local
fitness professional,
we're looking at things where
you want to become somebody
who helps inspire other people.
And one of the ways
that you do that
is becoming an
instructor, being a coach.
And a lot of places that
employ people like that
are asking for things like
your photography portfolio.
They want to know what
modeling photos you have.
They want to know how
many followers you
have on your social media.
And social media is a space
where conventional beauty
is still very highly ranked.
So again, as somebody
who's not a parent,
but wants to support
young women developing
into that athletic
field, how do we get
involved in supporting
women, young girls,
now, so that we develop
them into parents,
like you, who are
confident enough
to raise their children
to grow up in this world
where social media is
possibly going to tell them--
do you want this job?
Do you want to inspire
other people through sports?
Be pretty in a picture.
KATE T. PARKER: Mm-hm.
Yeah, that's so hard.
ANDREW FERENCE: There's like--
I mean, social media
is crazy for me.
Like I said, I have a
13-year-old daughter,
so you see the worst of it.
But there's so much good there.
There's so much good.
And I send her pages and posts
constantly that highlight--
you know, we all skateboard,
so girls skateboarding,
so a good trick, or there's
some great follows on rugby.
The girls that are playing
rugby for the [INAUDIBLE]
down in New Zealand, or
some of their training
videos of workouts they're
doing, and your book, you know?
KATE T. PARKER: Yeah.
ANDREW FERENCE: When I was
introduced to Kate's work,
I was like, oh, my god,
this is incredible.
Bought her book, gave it to
my girls, read it with them.
Our bedtime stories
are rebel girls for--
you know?
Like those great books
that tell stories.
But sometimes those social
media platforms, I think,
they can be utilized for
so much good, because you
control the message.
You control what you're
putting out there.
So I get that, sometimes, the
really cheesy Instagram beauty
model that's just doing the
empty shots, like the sport
model, come on, you can tell
she doesn't play sports.
Yeah, she might have
a ton of followers,
but there's a huge
market for people
that don't like that, that
like the real athlete.
Look at cross-fit, the explosion
of the cross-fit athlete.
Those are strong athletes.
They have a massive following.
That's a huge market.
So I think that will
always exist over here,
like the pure
empty beauty stuff.
That's going to happen, but
there's access now for our kids
and for everybody to follow
really great content, as well,
and have unbelievable
role models
and to actually do
that themselves.
I know my daughter, when
she's doing her Instagram
stuff, her big thing now,
she wants to get verified.
Right?
[LAUGHTER]
So we have the talk.
I'm like, well, you've
got to have good content.
And she's actually
putting thought into,
like, all right,
the stuff that we're
doing for drills in the gym,
and I'm doing all these sport
things, yeah, I can
build up a profile
of being a strong, 13-year-old
girl doing all this cool stuff.
KATE T. PARKER: Yeah.
ANDREW FERENCE: And
I was like, yeah.
100%.
Be one of those leaders
and one of those people
that can inspire other girls.
Just like you follow
all these girls
around the world doing
all this great stuff,
people will follow you
and be inspired by you.
And I just think that you can
use these platforms for so
much good, as well.
KATE T. PARKER: Yeah, I agree.
I think the more that we put
out honest, realistic depictions
of women and women athletes, I
think people respond to that.
I think if you talk about--
I always tell my kids,
I feel like there should
be a class for
digesting social media,
to recognize that's not
real, that's facetuned,
that is Photoshoped,
that is not her kitchen,
she's not at that
beach every day.
It's like, she went once and
changed outfits 25 times.
Like, yeah.
So I feel like if you
put honesty out there,
and you're real, and you
talk about your struggles,
your failures, your victories,
people respond to that.
I mean, that's who I
follow on social media
is people that are real, and
honest, and post the truth.
And I think, for my kids--
yeah, I have a 13-year-old too.
And it's hard because you
look, and you're like,
I didn't know you were friends
with her, but you're posting,
I love you.
You're so beautiful.
And you're like, OK, let's
have a conversation about what
this is.
But yeah, it's really
difficult. But I think the more
that you can put
honesty out there,
then you may not have
as many followers,
but I feel like your followers
are going to be really engaged
and also probably who
you want, you know?
ANDREW FERENCE: That's
Ava Ference too,
if you want to
give her a follow.
Help her get verified.
KATE T. PARKER: Or a blue check.
ANDREW FERENCE:
You're welcome, Ava.
AUDIENCE: So both of you have
daughters who are older than--
we have a three-and-a-half
year old daughter.
And we try to be very
conscious and make an effort
to not comment on
appearance and not
steer her in any
gender-specific direction.
And Halloween this
year, she dressed up
as a super monkey, which
we thought was awesome.
[LAUGHTER]
ANDREW FERENCE: Awesome.
AUDIENCE: But then
like, every single one
of her friends in pre-school
was dressed up as a princess.
And then we're
starting to worry,
is she going to just pick
up on this from her peers
and be like, oh, this is
what I'm supposed to do?
And you must have
been through this.
I'm wondering if
you have advice.
Can we do anything to
prevent peer pressure
from just subverting
everything we've tried to do?
ANDREW FERENCE: Oh, I
mean, I know that story.
KATE T. PARKER: Yeah.
It's pervasive.
ANDREW FERENCE: Yeah.
KATE T. PARKER: Yeah.
ANDREW FERENCE: I always took
the approach with my kids
that-- like, I grew up, I
was really into punk rock.
And so I would
wear the big docs,
and I had crazy haircuts,
all kinds of stuff.
So I'd show them pictures
of me growing up.
And I was like
the weirdo, right?
But I always take that
approach with them.
I'm like, you
know, what's really
important is to be weird,
to own your weirdness
and be different.
I'm like, how are you
going to stand out
from the crowd, if you want to
be special and do something?
All kids have these big dreams,
and they want to do big things.
And how do you say, OK, you
want to be an astronaut.
Great.
You realize, to be
an astronaut, you
have to be different
from everybody else.
You have to work hard.
You have to do all these things.
And being different
is actually great.
So celebrating not
being part of the crowd,
I totally bring out the
punk rock rah, rah speech
all the time, because I
really think that it really
is incredible to
stand out in a crowd,
and to embrace the
differences that you bring
to a room of people, and to make
yourself have a true identity.
And I always kind of took
the approach too to them,
I said, do you know what's a
really great compliment when
somebody has to describe
you, and it's hard for them
to describe you.
Like it takes a lot of words.
It's not just like, oh,
he's the hockey player.
You know?
I don't know, I don't know
if it's the perfect answer,
but that's the
approach we've taken.
And I think that
embracing your weirdness,
and embracing your
idiosyncrasies,
and all these little differences
you have from the group,
if you can celebrate that
and say, that's your power,
being different is like a
superpower, it's worked for us,
I think.
KATE T. PARKER: I mean, that's
exactly what we tell our kids.
And that's exactly,
when I do talks
to girls, that's what I say.
I say, the thing that makes you
stand out, the thing that you
might not be proud of
right now, but the thing
that makes you
different is exactly
the thing that you
need to focus on
and the thing that you need
to, sort of like-- that
is the thing that is
the best part about you.
And you really need
to pay it attention.
So if you tell her
when she shows up,
and there's all princesses,
and she's the one super monkey,
you should be like, oh, my
god, look at how great this is.
I mean, that's a weird costume.
That's awesome.
ANDREW FERENCE:
That is so awesome.
KATE T. PARKER: You know?
I think, if she gets
the reaction from you,
especially at three-and-a-half,
how cool is that,
you don't look like anybody
else, look at how different,
yeah, If you celebrate that,
then that will become part
of what she recognizes
when she's not with you.
Like oh, I'm different.
That's awesome.
ANDREW FERENCE: And
the best part about
that, it's not a lie.
KATE T. PARKER: Yeah.
ANDREW FERENCE: What
was our reaction when
you said super monkey?
We were like, oh, sick.
That's awesome.
It's true.
People respond positively
to those things, right?
So you're not even
selling her a lie.
It's the truth.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I have an older boy
and a younger daughter.
She's eight months now.
So she gets all
the hand-me-downs.
And so obviously, a lot of it
is boyish colors, and trucks,
and whatever.
And so my wife is
fine with that.
But I'm more of like,
you know, we have a girl,
so now we can get her dresses
and lots of pink and whatnot.
So I'm wondering, how much
does that really influence them
as they're getting older?
Or at one point,
are they just going
to be like, well, I don't
care how you've dressed me
in the past, I want
to be this person,
and I want to dress this way.
KATE T. PARKER: I'm trying
to think when they--
I mean, I think my
kids were always,
from when they could talk, were
always very clear about what
they wanted to wear.
Like this one just wanted to
wear pajamas for like two years
straight.
And I was like, all right.
I think as long as you, when
they have a voice, that you
hear their voice, and
you listen to them,
and you give them the power
to, I don't want to wear that,
or I do want to wear pink.
Like that's the thing.
I don't have an issue with pink.
I don't an issue
with princesses.
It's just, if that's
what you want to do.
I love pink.
If you want to wear that, great.
But if you don't
want to wear that,
I just don't feel like
you should be shoehorned
into it, as a girl or a boy.
But yeah, I think
as long as when
they have a decision making and
they're making their decisions,
as long as you are
listening to that--
but now, I mean,
when they're babies,
you can kind of-- that's like,
you have a very small window
of you can make them look like--
put them in a monkey
costume, or whatever.
But yeah.
So I think as long as
when they have a voice,
you start to listen to
it, that's important.
ANDREW FERENCE: Yeah,
we've done everything
from Disney princesses-- and
I mean now, like one day,
it'll be the unicorn onesie.
And the next day, it's like
the Thrasher skateboard hoodie.
It's just, they have their
arsenal for whatever mood
they're in, or whatever
they want to be that day.
Right?
But I mean, yeah, their voice.
Let them drive the bus.
KATE T. PARKER: Yeah.
ANDREW FERENCE: When
they're young, I don't know.
KATE T. PARKER: Yeah.
ANDREW FERENCE: I
can't even think--
I can't even remember what we--
I think we did girl's
clothes, or whatever.
KATE T. PARKER: Yeah,
we did girl-- yeah.
ANDREW FERENCE:
It's not poisonous.
KATE T. PARKER: Yeah.
Yes.
[LAUGHTER]
ANDREW FERENCE: But yeah,
just like everything.
Yeah, I don't know.
I never put that
much thought into it,
but we always let them pick
what they want to wear.
KATE T. PARKER:
No, but I get that.
I remember when I--
because my oldest was
bald for two years.
I would always get upset
when somebody would
be like, oh, what's his name?
And I'm like, oh, my god,
it's a girl, obviously.
But I get it, if you're
constantly saying,
oh, no, this is a girl,
because she's maybe in blues,
or whatever.
But yeah, I think now,
do whatever you want.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Great.
I know we're close on time,
but just a quick question.
Thank you guys, again,
for coming again.
So twofold question.
The first is, I know
working for the NHL, Andrew,
I am really curious, especially
talking about your work
with youth and how you're
looking to promote the game
and grow the game, what the
responsibilities you think of
are professional bodies
and governing bodies
for women's youth
specifically, as well.
I know in general,
just the access
to resources for youth
sport, especially the NHL
as a men's league--
there's a separate NWHL--
how do you guys view
your responsibility
and the responsibility of
governing bodies in general
towards promoting sports
equally between genders?
And then sequentially,
I think that there's
a pretty wide consensus
now, like "Strong
is the New Pretty," women
or girls specifically,
should be doing sports
and can do anything.
But a lot of that perception--
and you pointed out,
Kate-- around puberty,
things start to change a lot.
And access and
participation in sports
precipitously drops off, once
girls hit puberty and hit 18.
So I just wanted to
get your perspective
on both governing
body responsibilities
and professional body
responsibilities,
as well as what
the future of-- you
know, you're a good strong girl,
but be a strong woman later--
and how you see that transition.
ANDREW FERENCE: You're bang on.
I think there is a
massive responsibility.
And I think that,
for the most part,
we're taking our first strides
on deliberately supporting
female-specific hockey.
Well, just a couple
weeks ago, we
supported Hayley
Wickenheiser's tournament.
She's one of the greatest hockey
players of all time, Canadian.
She runs an all-girls
hockey festival.
And so the way we approach
it is, it's not just a hockey
tournament where they
go play the games
and then get the
medals and stuff.
What she does is she
has hockey games,
but then she has all
this off-ice activity.
So you have women
empowerment sessions,
and you have sports
sampling where
you can go try wrestling
with the female Olympian
wrestler who won a gold medal.
She had the prime
minister's wife
come in and give a panel
on the power of women
involved in sport.
And so these girls are coming
to this hockey tournament,
and yeah, they're
playing hockey,
but then they're at the
arena the entire day
doing all these other
really powerful things
and having this
great experience,
while playing hockey.
So at the NHL level, we look
at things like that and say,
100%, this is what
we have to support.
Like I said, we're not
trying to build necessarily
the next generation
of NHL players,
we're trying to build the
next generation of people
that just love hockey.
And obviously, from a business
decision, girls, boys,
everybody, we want to watch, and
be a fan, and enjoy the game.
So obviously, from a business
sense, it makes a lot of sense.
I mean, it'd be crazy to
ignore the female market,
but just because it's the
right thing to do, as well.
Our sport, the
participation levels
in both Canada and
the US, we've actually
gone up in the last couple
of years only because
of female participation.
Girls hockey is taking off
like crazy all over the place--
California, even down
in Texas and Las Vegas,
now that they have a team.
It's insane when
you see the growth
in the female part of our game.
And really, for
the most part, we
have some clubs that are doing
incredible things at a city
level.
But as the NHL,
like I said, we're
in our first strides of
deliberately supporting
female hockey and giving
them resources and supporting
their tournaments.
And even just yesterday,
for the last two days,
actually, at headquarters,
we had 12 powerful women
from across our sport,
from broadcasting,
to executive levels,
to players, obviously.
But we're putting together
a strong advisory panel,
specific to help guide
us down that path.
My department's majority female.
My boss is female.
So I think that
that representation
is incredibly important at an
executive level of the NHL.
That's different.
Over the past few years
of our commissioner
bringing in strong
female leaders
into the highest
positions within NHL
to help make these decisions,
that's massive progress,
I think.
And it's because of, I think,
that responsibility, but also
good business.
KATE T. PARKER: Oh, and
then the second question
about the drop off
of girls in puberty
from sports, which is huge.
And I don't know how to fix
it, but that's something
that I definitely, moving
forward in 2019 as part
of "Strong is the New
Pretty", that we are looking
to give back in that way.
I mean, it could be
something simple and as easy
as some girls don't
have a sports bra,
and that is why they
are not participating.
Or just like there's
these certain barriers
that, because at that point
it gets really competitive,
and its travel,
and it's expensive,
but there's a lot of different
barriers that, I think,
if we can keep our
girls in sports,
I feel like it's such a
huge part of confidence
and self-worth that they
need at that age, more
than any other age.
And yeah, it's something
that I would really
personally like to focus
on, keeping girls in sports.
And there's so many different
reasons why they're dropping
out, that if there
is simple Band-Aids,
we can get all of the girls
in Georgia sports bras,
or pedometers, or something
like that, I would--
I don't know.
I think it's something
that we need to address,
because it definitely
affects strong women.
I played through college
and got so much out of it.
And it's such a huge part of
my work ethic today and sense
of confidence, I think, that
it's sort of like a tragedy
if people miss out on
that, if they love a sport.
That's the thing.
It doesn't have to be sports.
Whatever it is,
just find a passion
and invest yourself in it.
And I think it's just opening
the pathways for girls
to figure out what that is,
and then staying with it
and giving them the
avenue, and the path,
and the support to continue
with whatever they love.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
ANDREW FERENCE: Thank you.
SPEAKER 1: Perfect.
AUDIENCE: I've played rugby
for the last 12 years.
ANDREW FERENCE: Yes.
ANDREW FERENCE:
It's the best sport.
I love it.
I mean, hockey is the best.
Rugby is the second.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: Well,
Andrew, Kate, thank
you so much for being here.
[APPLAUSE]
ANDREW FERENCE: Thank you.
KATE T. PARKER: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]